[Music]  we came up with a new police drama I  think people are gonna instantly fall in  love with I think it's fantastic take a  look at this promo we made I'm gonna ask  you once more Lagrange where's the  cocaine where is the cocaine Lagrange  tell me or I swear to God I will stick  my hand up your ass and use you as a  catcher's mitt  did you know Tom Cruise was supposed to  play Kevin Bacon's part of footless  let's hear it for cocaine cocaine is  what we want right Lagrange good cop bad  cop Japanese cop cop and obsessed with  footman's cop one of them always gets  his man  [Applause]  yeah about time I've been in this  business a long time Richter I know a  winner when I sees one alright alright